Richmond Hill prison and Grenada some
450 inmates are incarcerated here a few
are allowed outside the biogas plant
needs a new load of liquid manure the
prison has been producing its own biogas
for several months and the prisoners are
responsible for keeping the gas flowing
like Loxley he's serving a sentence for
theft and has been here for half a year
the favorite part that you see is
pulling the manual in the back very
Moser to mix it up mix it up to get it
away you have to be soupy they said I
was like fun to me more than 100
kilograms of pig and khaldun are mixed
with water the slurry has to flow easily
through the loading pipe the prison runs
a form that covers several hectares so
there's always enough manure the inmates
work with the animals as part of their
rehabilitation program for unit problem
should see is when you don't read it to
smell like it should say like a pig you
know it's like the figures you see your
smelly nose
is that a problem for him no it's not a
problem because we're not doing I change
my clothes and it was like all peak
scent is gone the biogas is used mostly
to power the slaughterhouse for example
to heat water chickens are plunged into
it to loosen feathers before plucking
the excess dung left over at the end of
the process is gathered and used as
organic fertilizer it's enough that the
prison no longer has to buy chemical
fertilizer which is expensive on the
island nation
around 110,000 people live on Grenada
and five times that many tourists visit
every year the island feels like a
Caribbean paradise but here you'll also
find brown streams full of manure that's
runoff from farms and they feed directly
into the sea regarding Grenada of Condor
lion Haida in zucchini because Grenada
is such a small island the pollutants
quickly end up in the sea that's why
it's important to revise the process
right at the beginning of the chain
working with the farmers themselves so
we can avoid this ecological problem the
German development organization GI z
supports a pilot project on the island
to build 10 biogas facilities here
Grenadiers small size is an advantage
today they received a call for help from
someone who's not so easy to reach
farmers sherwin sandy lives with his
family in the middle of the rainforest
you wanna try this sure sure when
trained as a cook he's good when I met
my wife she told me that her mother has
a piece of land and when I came here I
fell in love with the place so I said
would you want to live here for the rest
of your life she said yes no problem and
every day after that we walked to live
in here you know what I need to do
Sherwin sells his homemade baked goods
at a local supermarket to meet his power
needs he used to have to transport gas
and tanks to his house so he decided to
invest in a biogas unit but it's more
complicated than he thought he mostly
uses plant waste as a feedstock material
at first it was just too hard to collect
the 5 cubic meters of material he needed
he had to get manure from other farms
well it would have taken like 2 weeks
and a half about to get all inside in
some cases I would have had to use my
bicycle to get from one point to the
next and I had to use a neighbor's car
to get the bigger bulk of it to come up
his personal biogas plant is producing
now and he'd like to fire up his large
oven but the small flames don't provide
enough heat
that's why project leader detail Horton
Vega has brought a technician along to
have a look
morning morning ok so you've started
drilling some of the holes right we
actually have some of the holes that you
see the ones at the end there right now
the biogas only comes through a few
small holes that the farmer has bored
himself he had to burrow the drill from
a neighbor for small farmers like
Sherwin putting in a biogas plant
doesn't come cheap the plants which are
produced in Germany cost around four
thousand euros but that includes
installation and troubleshooting yah
pieden mid in middle column we work with
local financing institutions with banks
and associations that can offer credit
to the farmers so that they can afford
to buy a plant pay back the loan and
accrue some capital it's Island badeen
Dorothy IH bar owner and Gotha
Sherwin was lucky because he's taking
part in the pilot project he got the
plant for Half Price
another new plant is being installed on
the campus of a nearby college the
inmates from the Richmond Hill prison
are providing the labor it's also
training for the day they're released by
then they'll have acquired skills as
biogas experts
Loxley gets a special assignment he's
responsible for checking the interior of
the plant before the first batch of pig
dung is loaded this is Mikiko doctors in
peace when I calm walk feel like you've
had any fuel to have to learn something
when I leave now in Rockland if you or I
could learn something from that
when he's paroled in September Loxley
wants to work installing biogas plants
and the more plants that are built in
Grenada in the future the better his
chances of a new beginning